well what we are saying is that although
we're in an immeasurably better position
thanks to the vaccine program
we're still very much living with the
virus we're going to be for a long time
and so we do need to exercise
caution the the vaccine programs enable
us to move into a different
phase where it's not going to be a
matter of law
that these restrictions and inhibitions
remain in place but it will be a matter
of personal responsibility
and so we're asking every member of the
public to
be cautious to come to sensible
judgments about for example the wearing
of masks in close contact in indoor
spaces
and for businesses as well to consider
whether they want to and need to apply
those
restrictions and you can already see
that organizations such as
tfl which manages the tube in london
have come to
in my opinion a perfectly sensible
judgment that in the close confines of
the tube you should be using a mask and
there's also some supermarkets
that are coming to that conclusion as
well there are others though however in
the sector
sure there are others however in the
sector that are suggesting that it's
just
another confused mess i mean hugh osmond
founder of the restaurant group various
eateries
what was billed as freedom day is
actually going to be chaos day
i can't see how anyone is supposed to
know what to do it's wednesday and i
can't tell you what we're going to do on
monday
uh roger barker policy director at the
institute of directors
whilst it is right that companies should
be allowed to make their own decisions
based on their unique circumstances it
is vital that government provide
businesses
with best practice in developing their
own policies i mean all of this is just
simply passing the buck you talk about
personal responsibility you're
essentially handing all the
responsibility over to the
the business leaders the business
community and they don't know what to do
well i disagree with that we have
provided disagree with you osmond and
roger barker you've just quite
with respect i disagree with them we've
published guidance today which you've
been
quoting and the guidance reflects a huge
diversity of businesses
across the country if you're a business
that's operating
uh in a space where there's lots of room
it's very unlikely that people are
coming into close
contact then they'll come to a different
judgment to for example
waterstones who i understand have
announced that they
will be asking their customers to wear
masks and
you know some of their stores are quite
small people might be lingering
while they're reading books and that
seems again a logical
decision and so we trust businesses just
as we trust members of the public
to come to stem i'm not sure that the
business community would agree
i'm not sure the business community
would agree that you trust them and not
a
mention of vaccine passports past the
prime minister's lips when he announced
all of this on monday
we're now hearing that covered passports
could be used to get into bars and
restaurants
well no once again we're saying that
there will be some situations where
businesses
might choose to pursue these policies
using their best judgement and in my
experience going talk to
literally hundreds of businesses over
the course of the last year
this is the sort of discretion that they
want reflecting the fact that businesses
are often in very different situations
and a one-size-fits-all approach backed
by the force of the law
isn't sensible when we're moving into a
period now where
in all likelihood we're going to be
living with the virus for a long time
and we need to take a different approach
that's what we're doing and
personally i think that there's every
reason to believe that
members of the public and businesses and
operators of transport systems for
example
like the tram uh here in the west
midlands that those organizations
will come to sensible conclusions i
think but the evidence i've seen so far
from the businesses that have announced
their intentions they do seem to be
coming to logical
decisions or what they intend to do at
least initially then no doubt they'll
keep it under review as the fire just
progresses at part two of the uh
dimbleby food strategy released today uh
and an awful lot of talk around sugar
and salt taxes i mean first and foremost
is that something that the government is
considering and secondly i just wanted
to find out your views on
potentially sitting down to a plate full
of cultured meat which is another one of
the interesting proposals
uh being outlined today well this is an
independent
review was commissioned by government a
couple of years ago
uh but we haven't had any control over
uh the findings that uh richard dimbleby
has come to um they're they're henry
timberlake so they're interesting
uh findings that the environment sector
is going to consider them
and then bring forward our own food
strategy in the coming months so
i'm not going to comment on the
individual proposals
it does raise a very significant issue
for the whole country
clearly our relationship with food and
farming
is really important on a whole range of
different levels
from backing those businesses here in
the uk instilling a sense of pride
in us supporting local food obviously
health and health inequalities which are
even more prominent
as we come out of the pandemic and our
role internationally in striking trade
deals
and ensuring that we uphold high
standards for our food supply so there's
a lot of very important issues
that are raised by this report but we're
going to consider them carefully
and then set out our own proposals in
the coming months